c'est quoi la très grosse bêtise que tu
as fait
j'ai honte devant la famille il est
passé où là
[Musique]
tradition et dans la foi c'est ça que je
veux pour lui
disons là-bas tu racontes quoi de beau
il va falloir
oir
vous avez islamologie et théologique et
sinon vous aimeriez faire quoi
tu pourrais certainement faire un bon
immeuble imam c'est pas un métier
la parole elle touche
vous allez booster la nouvelle
génération
[Musique]
moi je veux que chacun d'entre vous
puisse un jour se rendre à La Mecque on
a mis un lien vers une cagnotte en bas
des vidéos je monte une auto-entreprise
et je fais des factures de temps en
temps
moi juste avec les réseaux je te ramène
300 fidèles
tu veux faire agence de voyage
[Musique]
je commence à m'inquiéter
ton histoire de visa ça sent mauvais
c'est une arnaque les actes ne valent
que par les intentions tu peux pas
prendre le Rosaire on joue pas avec
l'argent des gens comme ça surtout quand
tes initiatives ne sont pas dans le
périmètre de ta mission des mains
interroge ton attention
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le jeune humain
1h17 on est en direct merci abdoulah
d'être avec nous comment ça va ça va
très bien
merci à Nabil d'être là aussi merci
Nabil ça va mon chéri très bien merci
les gars ce film c'est un petit peu le
coup de cœur de l'équipe aussi à qui
fait et c'est vrai qu'on voit très peu
en promo et nous je dis mais moi c'est
quoi je vais recevoir voilà le jour de
la sortie et le film d'ailleurs marche
très bien je vous dis à très bien
démarré et les critiques sont très
bonnes bravo à vous c'est vrai que c'est
un c'est ton premier gros rôle
Abdullah promis en sortant de de l'école
de théâtre avec une école de théâtre et
deux mois après je tombe sur ce casting
je vois on cherche un jeune homme noir
25 ans qui s'est récité les sourates je
me suis dit c'est moi je suis obligé
d'avoir ce casting je suis obligé de
l'avoir et donc là direct a passé le
casting qui me champion il a il a craqué
sur toi bah ouais on peut dire ça comme
ça hein
je passe le casting je les rencontre du
coup très Honor très honoré très content
parce que je connais leur parcours j'ai
vu tout ce qu'ils ont fait et après
voilà un casting qui dure trois mois
c'était pas facile même si le tournage
c'est dur c'est dur de tournage le
tournage était dur même les on a fait
beaucoup de répétitions avant aussi
c'était c'était dur mais j'avais envie
quoi j'avais envie et comme c'est une
histoire qui me touche un peu
particulièrement dans le sens où j'ai
vécu un peu une partie de cette histoire
je voulais absolument je voulais
absolument réussir à avoir ce rôle quoi
alors
Nabil on le voit ce film va montrer
l'islam d'une manière qu'on voit peu
l'islam du quotidien celui de 2 millions
de de français c'était ça l'objectif ou
pas tout à fait c'était montré vraiment
les les musulmans sous sous le
musulmans de tous les jours en fait ce
qu'on vit tous les jours tout ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers tous les jours
et on n'a pas voulu faire ni un film
prosélyte ni un film à charge non plus
donc on a on a on a jonglé et
on a pour moi on a réussi vu que
là on est là ce soir et que tu nous
accueilles gentiment donc voilà et puis
qui est allé vous voir nombreux dès ce
premier jour donc c'est ça on a des très
bons retours pour l'instant par rapport
au sol donc c'est une très bonne
nouvelle très très bonne nouvelle très
bonne nouvelle et on espère que ça va
continuer comme ça on parle de ces
arnaques aux pèlerinage parce que ça
c'était pour c'est pour ça c'est que je
voulais vous recevoir ce soir parce que
ce sont des choses qui existent
réellement un Gilan absolument mais oui
il y a plein de d'agences notamment de
gens qui vous font miroiter des choses
et puis qui vous arnaque donc il faut
faire très attention et ce qu'il faut
dire aux gens c'est que il faut aller
voir votre film parce que c'est pas
militant c'est intelligent c'est pas
effectivement ça vous élite c'est fin
c'est sensible c'est l'islam apaisé
c'est l'islam des musulmans qui sont
intégrés à la société française avec
leurs problèmes leurs difficultés leur
enthousiasme et il faut que ce soit
diffusé dans le maximum de salles
possibles ça ce serait bien et que tout
le monde y aille ça je vous dis bravo
non mais ils viennent ils sont gentils
tu vois tu leur gueule dessus calme-toi
là tu as les veines qui sortent là tu
vas nous faire un AVC bêtement non mais
c'est tu vas nous faire un ABC bêtement
l'autre elle va rien comprendre elle va
dire que j'arrivais dans l'émission il y
avait un vieux il était en route
voilà calme-toi calme-toi alors ça va
ils sont très content d'être là alors
non c'est vrai qu'il y a des personnes
qui perdent toutes leurs économies donc
c'est important de dire c'est ça que
vous vouliez montrer aussi c'est ça
aussi montrer ma roulez pas montrer que
les bons côtés non plus de l'islam c'est
ça voilà ça veut dire qu'on a montré un
peu les difficultés que vivent aussi les
musulmans au quotidien et après moi dans
ma tournée parce que j'ai j'ai on va
dire bosser entre guillemets en mode
bénévole parce que ce film-là
malheureusement il a pas bénéficié d'une
grande aide donc voilà donc j'ai
travaillé avec pas mal d'assaut j'ai
travaillé avec les mosquées j'ai
travaillé aussi avec des prêtres
pour pouvoir travailler sur ce film là
j'ai travaillé avec le père de l'homme
de Lyon qui est connu par rapport à la
marche des beurre bien sûr donc qui m'a
accueilli et j'ai fait presque trois
heures de discussion avec lui et il m'a
il m'a ouvert les portes sur pas mal de
contacts à lui avec des associations
avec qui travailler pour pouvoir faire
vivre ce film et pour avoir le résultat
qu'on a aujourd'hui ici avec avec le
nombre d'entrée qu'on a aujourd'hui ça
va continuer ça va continuer on l'espère
clairement vous sentez que le film fait
peur à certains parce que depuis les
premiers festivals vous sentez que le
film malheureusement fait peur notamment
à cause du titre on a vu qu'il y avait
très peu de promos pour ce film vous
l'avez senti ça ou pas en fait c'est
[Musique]
nous on le on le sort comme ça ça veut
dire comme un
boycott qui n'est pas officiel je sais
pas si tu vois ce que je veux dire mais
en gros donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
parti on va dire en guerre
malheureusement c'est un terme assez dur
mais on est parti en guerre nous-même et
on a on a fait le boulot nous-même pour
faire parler de ce film là et donc on a
travaillé avec pas mal de monde pour
pour vraiment pour vraiment développer
le film et faire parler de ce film mais
le faire connaître de tous sur toute la
France j'ai le problème c'est vrai que
c'est quoi le problème avec le film le
titre c'est le titre c'est le titre le
jeune imam c'est que le fait que imam
dedans ça c'est un problème alors imam
est jeune comme si on l'avait obligé
alors bah oui parce que le jeune imam
comme si on avait obligé à aller à
l'école coranique alors que l'école
coranique c'est formateur c'est ce qui
est montré dans le film là encore une
fois c'est pas du tout de prosélytisme
mais aujourd'hui en France quand on
parle de l'islam dans l'Islam apaisé et
ben ça choque quand même il des gens qui
du coup pensent que ça va créer des
problèmes etc donc il y a des salles
Cyril qui me diffusent pas le film il
faut le dire clairement il a pas le
nombre de salles qu'il méritent et ça
c'est très triste
justement il y a des grandes villes
communion je crois il y avait que deux
scènes au début qui avait accepté de
diffuser le film qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
disent les salles que c'est un sujet qui
fait peur qui dérange après
malheureusement on est arrivé juste pour
les avant-premières on arrivait au
moment où cri de sortait et sans avoir
sans avoir vu le film on a été un petit
peu comparé par rapport à ce film là où
il y a eu des bagarres en salle et donc
sur les sur les avant-premières sur les
avant-premiers en fait ils veulent pas
c'était pas ne pas diffuser le film
c'était faire des avant-première avec
débat qu'il est qui qui a dérangé
certains mais après voilà on peut les
comprendre aussi
dans le sens où cri d'affaires a fait
pas mal de
ils ont eu cette petite appréhension et
complètement différents
pour moi personnellement et c'est ce que
je dis à chaque fois on aurait pu
appeler ce film là le jeune prêtre le
jeune rabbin le jeune bouddhiste le
jeune ce que vous voulez l'histoire en
elle-même n'aurait pas changé c'est à
dire que l'islam est le fond c'est c'est
un décor dans ce film là parce que la
famille est musulman mais voilà ça veut
dire que là le film pour nous il est pas
basé sur l'islam on va voir après voilà
c'est un film qui parle d'Islam par
rapport à l'histoire dans laquelle on
est mais ça aurait été le jeune prêtre
ou le jeune rabbin c'est l'histoire
n'aurait pas changé ça aurait été la
même chose
et les gens anticipent en fait et je
vais sur ce mot là pour pas aller pour
être en fait quand tu vois le titre ils
anticipent
certains problèmes avant d'aller voir le
film et ça donc pour eux ils ont ce
petit pas de recul quand ils voient le
gène imam c'est une vraie histoire
est-ce que mais c'est des deux côtés ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que les
musulmans comme les noms musulmans même
les musulmans
c'est-à-dire que même eux ont un pas de
recul par rapport à ce film-là
en se disant est-ce qu'on va pas être
stigmatisé nous aussi et c'est là que
Rachid Benzin nous avait dit une très
jolie phrase par rapport à ça en me
disant bah on se rend compte que les
musulmans en fait sont des Français
comme les autres et donc voilà ils ont
le même pas de recul que tout le monde
quoi merci en tout cas Nabil abdoulah
ça a bien dit moi je pense que il faut
il faut pas s'arrêter au titre comme
comme on l'a dit le titre il peut être
trompeur c'est une histoire d'amour
c'est une histoire d'amour entre une
mère et son fils et c'est plein
d'histoires que qui met l'age
on met dans ce film on raconte les
jeunes qui sont envoyés au pays pour
apprendre la religion on n'avait jamais
traité de ce sujet là on raconte aussi
les arnaques au pèlerinage on parle
aussi des images sur les réseaux sociaux
donc ouais c'est un condensé de plein
plein d'histoires plein d'histoires
intéressantes donc ne vous arrêtez pas
au titre et foncez voir ce film parce
que il faut foncer voir le film le jaune
qui est sorti aujourd'hui merci à vous
deux je voulais vous avoir absolument
[Applaudissements]
voilà tous les amis exactement voilà et
qui ont fait un travail de fou
à tous en gros que ce soit l'âge qui
est exactement j'en Rachid Toufik
qui nous ont donné de la force pour
pouvoir faire ce film je voudrais
remercier aussi les gens qui m'ont aidé
pour l'instant
[Rires]
remercie parce que c'est le seul
festival qui nous a accueillis et on a
pris trois prix quand même on s'est pris
le meilleur film meilleur premier rôle
les meilleurs chevaux rôles donc c'est
bien bah c'est voilà merci à vous deux
je vais juste remercier tous les acteurs
et actrices avec qui j'ai travaillé pour
le film le coach qui m'a fait bosser
Sébastien Davis et Steve tiens
moi aussi je peux dire des noms
[Applaudissements]
et Guillaume Fourcade voilà merci moi
pour
toi
[Musique]
c'est un film pour tous ma mère ça fait
50 ans qu'elle est en France elle avait
jamais été au cinéma de sa vie c'est le
premier film qu'elle a été voir au
cinéma on l'embrasse donc voilà je
voulais lui faire un coucou et bon après
voilà et en même temps dire à tout le
monde c'est un film où vous pouvez
emmener vos parents ça veut dire que
c'est un film pour tous de 7 à 77 ans
Daniel elle pourra pas
voilà
merci merci à vous tous
[Applaudissements]